for our daily cancellation today we have
a classic reverse cancellation where we
cancel the cancellers and it begins with
a sushi restaurant now if you're
chronically online then you probably
already know where this is going I don't
know what that says about you or me or
the world but when I say we're doing a
cancellation related to a sushi
restaurant many of you have already
filled in many of the details in your
head before hearing any of the details
so um for those who whose Souls have not
become so jaded here's what happened as
a Daily Caller reports quote an
australian-born restaurant owner who set
up shopping New York City is
experiencing a flurry of negative online
reviews for being white and owning a a
sushi uh restaurant when Sushi counter
opened its doors it was committed to
serving affordable Australian style
handrolled Mai in the Big Apple where
prices are typically Skyhigh the public
will reported recently however the
restaurant has been subjected to
negative reviews by online users who
were put off by the fact that the owner
Alex is white one vocal Chef Eric Rivera
took to Twitter in a now deleted thread
to shun Sushi counter for being uh owned
by a colonizer white woman suggesting
that she has no place serving the widely
popular Japanese favorite according to
the public this is not the first time
that Rivera has dubbed others tied to
the culinary industry as colonizers
according to his Twitter post Sushi
counter had previously receiv received
positive reviews by NYC Sushi fans
according to the outlet the owner
reportedly deleted a Tik Tok page that
she made documenting her journey of
opening the business the backlash also
came with a flurry of negative Google
reviews now to be clear these are
negative Google reviews panning the
restaurant based on the race of the
owner and this is the kind of thing that
can only possibly go one way in our
culture of course here are a few of
those reviews quote there are plenty of
good authentic sushi spots in this city
and prices aren't crazy I suggest going
to one of those this is a colonizer
sushi spot ran by a woman who thinks
that she can do better than actual
Japanese people another reviewer wrote
enough of the gentrification the last
thing anyone needs are blond hair
Australian white women appropriating
Japanese Cuisine we're sick of the
disrespect inflicted Upon Our cultures
by white people enough is enough now of
course the backlash against the white
owned sushi restaurant went beyond
Google on Twitter a woman named deedre
um deedre goldor who is a financial
adviser and a self-described quote
cultural historian and goes by the
handle queer Latifa uh posted this why
is someone who is not of Asian descent
better yet from Australia opening a
sushi spot in NYC she continues the
contradiction and cognitive dissonance
is maddening she feels she can't afford
decent Sushi and NYC a place that has
one of the largest and vastly diverse
Asian populations so instead she
finances her own Sushi Spot colonization
is white and quite scary to see in real
time and that tweet has thousands of
likes and supportive comments by the way
a tweet that describes a sushi
restaurant as both maddening and scary
now as a sane person myself I can't
fathom how how anyone could conjure
those kinds of emotions in relation to a
sushi
restaurant and I suppose we could assume
that the emotions are fake and that it's
all performance and that could well be
the case but we also can't discount the
possibility that some of these people
are indeed as unstable and irrational as
they present themselves to be now there
are a number of obvious points that we
could make here and and we we'll make
them because you know stating the
obvious is what the show is all about
and the first and most obvious thing is
that this deranged standard is only ever
applied to white people and would never
and has never gone the other way right
like you you'll never hear of a of a of
a pizza place being bombarded with
negative reviews because it's owned by
an Asian guy or a burger joint being
protested because it's run by a you know
Hispanic woman you'll certainly never
hear anyone telling a black Chef what
sorts of Cuisine he isn't allowed to
cook based on his race indeed if we
really wanted to play this game equally
then we would say that not only can a
white person open a sushi restaurant in
the United States but in fact arguably
only white people should open sushi
restaurants or any other kind of
restaurant in the United States if we
apply the racial logic of wokeism
consistently across the board that's
where it leads this is a predominantly
white uh historically white country and
therefore all of our restaurants should
be operated by white people except we
don't say that because it would be
insane just as it's insane going the
other
direction second once again you know the
woke crowd is insulting the people that
they're supposedly standing up for
notice how queer Latifa says that Sushi
should be handled by the city's diverse
Asian population which first of all
seems to suggest that it's the job of
Asian people to provide her with
delicious sushi and which also directly
implies that all Asians are the same
like sushi is a Japanese dish
historically she says it's an Asian dish
but why would someone from say Mongolia
is an Asian country automatically be
better suited to make Sushi than someone
from Australia like how does that logic
work how is this any different from like
walking into a room of strangers and
searching for the most Asian looking
person you can find and then walking up
to them and asking them for a good
recommendation to a sushi restaurant or
maybe asking them for karate
lessons this is stereotyping and it's
lumping people of various ethnicities
together just because they live on the
same continent and the left does this
thing all kind of thing all the time
note how they constantly refer to
indigenous or Native American culture as
if the disparate array of tribes spread
out across the hemisphere all all shared
one culture or shared anything at all
for that matter people always say happy
dog happy life well if that's really the
case you need to be giving your dog
rough greens naturopathic Dr Dennis
black the founder of rough greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America before I started feeding
my dog Ruff greens I had no idea that
dog food is dead food it turns it
contains very little nutritional value
think about it nutrition isn't Brown
it's green let rough grain bring your
dogs food back back to life rough greens
is a supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it get a free jump
trial bag delivered straight to your
door in just a few business days go to
Ru greens.com mat or call 844 ru700
that's r uff greens.com matat or call
844 Ru 700
today finally we have the um of course
the inherent Madness behind the idea of
cultural appropriation and you would
think that the people who love to see
everything as as fluid and on a spectrum
and as a human construct would
understand that culture is by definition
the most fluid human construct of all
culture is simply the Customs Traditions
arts and institutions of any group of
people and those custom traditions arts
and institutions and and their their
cuisine as well are always evolving
they're always in constant exchange with
other cultures and especially in this
day and age that process is is in
hyperdrive because we're even more
connected than we've ever been before
this is why even if it made sense to
accuse one culture of stealing something
from another culture which it doesn't
because theft deprives the victim of the
thing being stolen but nobody is being
prevented from wear from from eating
sushi or making sushi just because one
white woman opened up a sushi shop but
still uh you know we couldn't identify
who is actually guilty of stealing from
who humans have been making culture in
some form or another for tens of
thousands of years for most Trends and
Fashions and Foods it's not possible to
identify a definitive date or place of
origin even if you could what influenced
the person who came up with it and what
influenced the influences of that person
and so on in fact as I was um preparing
this uh monologue I found myself falling
down a Wikipedia rabbit hole about the
origins of sushi because I was just kind
of curious and it turns out that Sushi
probably originates from the practice of
fermenting fish and storing it in rice
and that practice um does not originate
in Japan it originates in uh in South uh
Southeast Asian cultures um thousands of
years ago most likely but um nobody
knows for sure the exact place of origin
and if it does originate there like how
was that practice picked up what was it
based on and where did the thing that it
was based on originate in fact where did
the practice of eating fish come from
originally who was the first person who
ever thought like we should go into this
body of water and try to find the
creature in there and eat it what was
the first time that ever
happened what what what part of the
world how many Millennia do we have to
go back to find the origins of that and
what part of the
world did that person live in well it's
impossible to say Obviously which means
it's impossible to really enforce the
cultural appropriation rule to begin
with even if the rule was worth
enforcing which of course it certainly
isn't you wouldn't be able to and this
is wokeness for you morally atrocious
standards that are also totally
incoherent and impossible to abide by
consistently
that's what it's all about and is
ultimately why all of the people
canceling this sushi restaurant are
today themselves cancel if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed